last week's debate joe biden confirmed
his plan to abolish the entire
u.s oil industry would you close down
the earth by the way i have a transition
from the oil industry yes
oh transition it is a big statement will
you remember that texas would you
remember that pennsylvania oklahoma vice
president i'm not
shutting down oil fields i'm not
eliminating fracking i'm investing in
clean energy and we're going to make
sure
that we don't continue to subsidize the
oil companies
former vice president biden popping into
pennsylvania about 45 minutes from his
his house today as the president made
three stops in pennsylvania
with big big crowds at these events
there's one from allentown earlier in
the day i made two more stops through
the day
uh all outside and the president
sometimes going on for a long time now
he's on his way
driving back to the airport marine one
had some weather issues he'll be back
for an event this evening
for the swearing-in of judge amy coney
barrett let's bring in our expanded
panel fox news senior political analyst
brit hume ben dominic popular publisher
of the federalist mar liason national
public political correspondent national
public radio there you go
and chris starwall politics editor here
at fox news
brit you look at these rallies and
people we look back to 2016 and they say
remember all the big rallies you had for
president trump then candidate trump at
the
this time do you read anything into
these rallies
well i would size it up this way brett
we didn't think four years ago that
rally size were really a good indicator
and they turned out that they were
but at this stage i think it it looks
like this
trump is behind in the polls he's well
behind in money but he's ahead
and probably way ahead on voter
enthusiasm the problem for him
is that an unenthusiastic vote
cast are they this time
you know i don't rule it out but i don't
think it's what i'd bet on
yeah mara you had the former vice
president pop in to pennsylvania
late in the day it was not scheduled if
you take a look at the calendar
today uh the president had those three
stops as i mentioned in pennsylvania
tomorrow
uh vice president biden is in georgia
warm springs in atlanta
the president's in lansing michigan
wisconsin and
nebraska we don't have a schedule for
the vice president on wednesday
the president's in arizona two stops on
wednesday
thursday biden's in florida two stops
friday
iowa and wisconsin and the president has
pledged to do more stops
obviously later in the week he's clearly
going out to the barnstorming
effort right there's no doubt
that he you know the big rallies the
packed schedule
that's part of his brand and i think
he's making trying to make the argument
look
joe biden isn't as strong as me as
energetic as me
he keeps a very mild schedule but if you
look at that calendar that you just
recited
donald trump by definition he was the
winner last time is playing a lot of
defense
but joe biden is going to places like
georgia and iowa
that shows you how confident the
campaign is the biden campaign is at the
same
time as they're not taking his birth
state for granted he was in pennsylvania
today
and doing a little cleanup about the
comments about the oil industry although
biden people tell me they haven't seen
any evidence
uh in their polling that that
gaff you could call it that statement uh
has
moved any votes well i mean
they consider it a gaff ben because they
spent all day kind of
trying to dial it back cleaning up but
they said but they're not seeing any
evidence yet that it's that it's
moving things in the midway got it i
understand what you're saying ben yeah
what about so the debate performance for
joe biden then you had
you know a lot of the focus on the 60
minutes uh piece was about
president trump and leslie stahl and the
president walking out
but but the interview with joe biden and
kamala harris that nora o'donnell did
take a listen to one little clip here
so are you going to bring the policies
those progressive policies that you
supported as senator
into a biden administration i will give
him that perspective and always be
honest with him
and is that a socialist or progressive
perspective no
no it is the perspective of of a woman
who grew up a a black child in america
who was also a prosecutor who also has a
mother who arrived here at the age of
19 from india who also you know
likes hip-hop what do you want to know
what did you make of that interview i
thought nora o'donnell did a nice job
pressing on substance
but it's really some of the more pointed
questions that senator harris
has received since becoming the nominee
it was kind of a demonstration of how
few questions she's gotten since being a
nominee in any capacity
that really challenge her she seemed to
be genuinely surprised when norah
o'donnell
put in front of her the fact that you
know the independent gov track
uh declares that kamala harris is the
most liberal member of the senate in
terms of her voting history she seemed
genuinely surprised
to learn that which i thought was kind
of interesting you know look if you look
at this situation right now brett
last time around in 2016 my experience
was the pollsters
were urging humility on the part of a
lot of the news reporters
when i was covering it for a different
network at that time
four years ago the attitude really was
let's be more humble let's have a little
humility here
about the numbers that we're seeing
let's not be eager to call it for
hillary clinton
this time around it seems like things
have flipped a bit the pollsters seem
very confident in their numbers they
seem to be
you know ready to say they've seen
enough especially at the congressional
district level
while there are a lot of reporters out
there and who who've paid a lot of
attention closely to this
race who see it more as a situation that
could come down to pennsylvania who
believe
that president trump might over perform
when it comes to the hispanic community
that we see
across the sun belt and in states like
florida and arizona
it's just interesting to me how that
dynamic has shifted and
i think a lot of people feel a little
snake bit by what they expected to
happen in 2016
they worried that that might happen all
over again
chris do you sense that democrats are
feeling a little anxious about
being this confident at this point
oh they're a wreck you there's nothing
like a good
hand to make a democrat a nervous wreck
and
uh they are reliving you know when i
talk to
people i know in biden world when i talk
to members of congress stuff like that
they are beside themselves because and i
can tell them anything i want about
margins of error and data and all of
that stuff
they don't care because they remember as
ben describes that horrible feeling of
snake bit
they were too confident in 2016 one of
the reasons biden has been so successful
this time around
is that they have played it as safe as
they possibly could
on all fronts and they have been very
careful not to
act braggadocious or overconfident and
that has frankly been good for them
and kept their voters motivated let me
play the sound bite from the white house
chief of staff over the weekend getting
a lot of attention britt
we're not going to control the pandemic
we are going to control the fact that we
get uh vaccines therapeutics and other
mitigations what are we going to get
because it is a contagious virus just
like the
but why not make efforts to contain it
well we are making efforts to contain it
and obviously the biden campaign quick
to say that this was a white flag waving
your thoughts brit
well if you look at what's happening in
much of europe now
when they're having new cases of course
you don't always know when you hear
about cases how sick anybody is and
and more more important than that how
likely they are to die
uh nonetheless there's a lot of alarm in
europe now a place where
experts in america were saying you know
they did it right over there and we
didn't
and therefore you know we're having the
spikes and they're not and now they are
which suggests what i think mark meadows
was getting at which is this is a highly
contagious disease
we are in the middle of it of a pandemic
people get sick
but outside of you know elderly people
or people with certain
pre-existing conditions the recovery
rate is
99 or more so that's the good news
so to say that we can't control it in a
sense we can't prevent there being more
cases
may just be common sense based on
experience
yeah i want to end with this sound bite
just because i found it interesting
going back to 2012
and something the former vice president
said on 60 minutes asked about the
biggest national security threat
governor romney i'm glad that you
recognize that al qaeda is a threat
because a few months ago when you were
asked what's the biggest geopolitical
threat facing america you said russia
not al qaeda you said russia in the
1980s are now
calling to ask for their foreign policy
back because you know the cold war has
been over for 20 years
first of all russia i indicated is a
geopolitical
foe not a number one excuse me it's a
geopolitical fault well i think the
biggest threat
to america right now in terms of
breaking up our
our security and our alliances is russia
well the staff took time to dig that up
so i wanted to play it panel thanks for
the time
i appreciate it when